i still live in media i'm just preparing
for my future
uh as a as a twitch streamer
for the rest of my life or the
indefinite future
[Music]
what's going on man it's steph yeah i
knows you stuff
i'm about to give you
some advice for the game
today just just do your thing you know
i talk to my friends about how you're
the me
of playing nba 2k so
we're excited to watch we're grabbing
our snacks
and we're gonna hang out and support
best of luck
i won't let you down enjoy your snacks
2k is weird because
sometimes people just they got to be
verified on here
so that's why it's a star uh above my
head like i'm some type of religious
figure
so people sometimes just stand around me
because of that instead of like playing
in a game you know what i think i'm
gonna
change my ethnicity real quick
let's see boom
i'm a black dude now so this is what
happens so people
they see that they come by you then they
start looking at their phone and look at
your stats
but then his his avatar is pretty weird
so
that's the thing even in the virtual
world
we don't really want weird looking
[ __ ] around us
well look i guess i got on a polka dot
cowboy hat
and i just changed from asian to black
red bone says the hat is
ugly well you know
you're ugly
[Applause]
let's see my dance hey
sometimes i'm not that great at shooting
wow he just beat me off the dribble oh
what a kick out he should have stayed
home
oh what the [ __ ]
that's damn
all right i'm gonna stand over here in
the corner try to get an open three
whoa ally hey nice one
good shot see y'all i'm not a selfish
player like that or sometimes i
am but i'm trying to uh get everybody
involved let's see
we up 87
oh splash
oh come on damn you killing
there we go splash
oh god dammit
i'm holding our team back and i'm just
uh
i guess i'm playing sound defense oh
go refresh double screen we open him up
green i'm a role player
[Laughter]
nope come on come on green that
yes god we just gotta get him open
for the three close it out
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey that's the beginning of a streak
who's next
oh look at this goddamn
oh hell no
oh no he's the center who's next
let's see we're about to cook these cats
[Music]
it's all good we about to go up 8-2
let's go oh hell no uh
damn whose man
is this
oh that was out of bounds
can i get a replay on that
oh no no
oh no
proximity is oh the air squad re-vex
and revax koala and brad oh
well yeah i yeah your friends become
your enemies
i'm going against my old teammates
wow
i wonder if they know what's at stake
for me wow
i don't know if even my teammates know
like the level of emotional investment i
have
in this game with it being my old team
i respect it reflex koala about the step
wow
[Applause]
wow
this some [ __ ] hey this some
[ __ ]
i don't like this
this is destroying my love for the game
[Music]
wow
all right we need to [ __ ] score we
can't go we can't get skunked
we gotta get up well
he doesn't believe oh he has both two
teammates all three of them are
on fire okay so we'll see
bradley don't skunk me man out of
respect adam's respect for our old
team like don't put me out of here
when the shot went up i just
thought about everything
[Music]
let's go refresh koala
double screen we opened him up great
i'm a role player yeah man
i don't know man i mean i mean i didn't
really know the [ __ ] man and [ __ ] owe
me some money
nope come on come on green that
let's go game
[Laughter]
oh let's go we all get corn dogs we all
get corn dogs
hey that's the beginning of a streak
who's next
who's next i was like what the
[ __ ] is he doing
[Music]
i knew it was over then
[Music]
i thought we were squat
thanks for watching guys like subscribe
[Music]
share
[Music]